thick stiff and shiny the prized malan
fabric bazan is sought after and
exported across West Africa baz used to
make traditional clothes worn for
weddings and religious ceremonies but
shop owner jila mamadu is warning his
customers in neighboring countries that
the cost of the fabric is about to go up
he tells them Molly's plan to leave the
Regional West African body echoo may
bring an end to the free movement of
people and goods like the precious
fabric
we already feel the pinch from the
current crisis add to that the impact of
living the echo us we will really suffer
and the government needs to review its
decision thousands of protesters are
gathering in mali's capital bamako they
support the decision by their military
rulers along with those of ner and
bukina Faso to leave the regional body
echos imposed sanctions on all three
countries following military coups power
Cuts in Maly and a fuel and food short
shortage in ner are affecting their
populations meanwhile attacks from armed
groups are on the rise it's a populist
move because they know that when the
union the block itself is putting
pressure on them to come back to
constitutional order which they're not
ready to do so uh withdrawing quitting
the the the community is a way to
extend uh they're staying in power
illegitimately of course for the
citizens of the three countries this
could mean they'll need visas to travel
and work in the region 5 million of them
live and work in Ivory Coast alone
custom duties may come into complicating
the movement of goods as well as people
according to statistics from the Sagal
government half of the products and
goods that Transit through the port of
Dar are destined to the landlock
countries of Mali ner and Bina Faso
their withdrawal from the regional body
echoo will have an impact on the
economies of the
[Music]
[Applause]
region it will be a year before the
split takes effect but many fear it
means more trouble for the region and
the 49 year-old Union meant to unite
African nations but now dividing them
Nicholas Hawk Al jazer
Dar make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer